[Musique]
Hélène buzati elle est castonguée
Véronique presse bonsoir
bonsoir les gens on se disent peut-être
ah ben voilà une autre subvention comme
les autres
usines puis ils prêtent à peu près pas
attention où
or c'est vraiment les il y a un grand
jeu qui est en train de se mettre en
place en Amérique du Nord les Américains
font mettre beaucoup d'argent pour
attirer les grands pour faire des
batteries toute la filière électrique
etc or Hélène le Canada suivi on le vu
avec l'exemple de Volkswagen en Ontario
l'on le voit avec JM au Québec si tu ne
parties d'échec qui se joue là
les fameuses règles de très généreuses
et ben les règles proposées par Ottawa
tomberait à l'eau mais oui on est en
train de se positionner en même temps ça
fait pleuvoir beaucoup de milliards et
ça amène certains quand même à
s'interroger oui d'ailleurs c'est fort
possible que les Américains changements
de président ou pas même soit moins
généreux compte tenu il y a des
négociations qui républicains
plafonnement de la dette donc mais en
attendant Alex sacré une pression au
Canada et au Québec monsieur le goût
d'ailleurs allait s'entendre en
conférence de presse nous aussi on veut
notre bout du gâteau là pour attirer ses
joueurs là on veut créer une synergie
c'est ou bien on joue dans le scénario
de la filière batterie des véhicules
électriques on ne joue pas dedans mais
il y a pas de milieu là donc ou bien on
se colta avec les Américains avec
l'Ontario dans le coq canadien avec la
France avec l'Allemagne avec la Corée
tous ces pays-là veulent attirer des
investissements pour la nouvelle filière
batterie les véhicules électriques la
logique veut que ces grands fabricants
là s'installe là où ils prod déjà des
véhicules aux États-Unis en Ontario dans
le code JM ça dépend des usines mais
dans le cas de Volkswagen en Allemagne
bien évidemment
la fabricant donc si au Québec on veut
une part du gâteau dans la famille la
filière batterie construit des éléments
de la batterie dans les cascades par
exemple pour JM ou dans les produits
chimiques pour BASF qui s'en vient le
géant allemand mais il faut être capable
de de subventionner de faire des prêts
c'est actuellement là c'est là que ça se
passe dans 5 ans il va être trop tard si
on veut construire une nouvelle
industrie qui sort de terre et ça arrive
pas souvent là une fois par génération
une fois par 50 ans où on crée le de
toutes pièces une nouvelle filière
d'automobile en Amérique du Nord c'est
pas mal là que ça c'est la main puis
sortir le chèque maintenant et derrière
c'est intéressant Hélène mais Véronique
je vous donne la parole vous avez fait
un gros dossier là-dessus on sait pas si
Monsieur poirierve sortirait le dossier
le chéquier autant je vais vous reposer
ça après mais Véronique vous aviez vous
nous aviez présenté en long et à l'arche
cette vision dans la vallée de la Saint
Maurice de faire un pôle d'attraction là
pour ce genre d'usine et puis pour
poursuivre sur ce que collègues disait
au Québec on est peut-être pas capable
de compétitionner de la même manière que
les Américains qui sortent l'argent leur
couple de millions milliards pour
attirer ces entreprises là mais ce qu'on
se dit au Québec c'est que bon nous on a
les universités puis on a une zone
d'innovation on est capable de créer un
espèce d'écosystème qui va les attirer
donc on a un bassin de chercheur puis en
plus on a l'hydroélectricité avec un
tarif à bas prix alors offrir alors là
c'est l'espèce de mode au gouvernement
d'offrir ce qu'on appelle des prêts
pardonnables dans les faits c'est comme
une subvention sauf qu'on exige en
retour certains critères comme dans ce
cas-ci on exige que les emplois soient
maintenus je pense pour une période de
10 ans et je peux vous assurer que pour
être aller sur place il déroule le tapis
rouge la société du parc industriel de
becancourt est là pour créer
l'infrastructure routière par exemple de
faire en sorte que tous les éléments
soient là pour qu'ils aient envie de
venir installer leurs usine vous voulez
un chemin de fer au nord au lieu d'Aude
parfait pour vous le faire vous voulez
un kit plus au port de Trois-Rivières on
va en construire un autre alors ils sont
prêts à tout leur donner finalement en
termes d'infrastructures pour les
attirer parce que la compétition
d'ailleurs je vous posais la question
Hélène avant de passer à l'autre sujet
ça va être intéressant de voir d'ici
quelques mois est-ce que ce poignet lui
serait prêt à donner autant d'argent ces
entreprises
la réponse est je ne sais pas parce
qu'on ne nous le dit pas on a posé
souvent à la question on a toujours pas
de réponse monsieur Poyet le chef
conservateur entretient un flou et c'est
quand même intéressant parce que
d'habitude on associe le Parti
conservateur la droite économique un
petit peu plus enlignée avec le milieu
de la finance le milieu de les
entreprises etc et donc on les
imaginerait à être d'accord avec ce
genre d'intervention économique alors
que le NPD à gauche plus susceptible par
exemple de parler de corporate le
bien-être social corporatif c'est
subventions que l'on donne puis qui nous
pas toujours ce qu'on veut alors là les
rôles sont inversés vous aviez
aujourd'hui le chef du NPD jugbything
qui disait eh oh est-ce que Ottawa va
allonger le chéquier ouvrir le chéquier
pour pouvoir à côté l'offre à Volkswagen
pour la donner à cet entier ce qui
réclame plus d'argent alors que le Parti
conservateur entretient un doute et
quand on entretient un doute ben
généralement c'est parce qu'on n'est pas
très très chaud à l'idée alors vraiment
une inversion des rôles une inversion
des rôles très bien Conseil Général du
PLQ avec je vous fais entendre je vous
fais entendre Jérôme Turcotte il a
peut-être vous avez lu ça dans la presse
c'était vendredi je crois ancien
président de la commission politique il
y était aussi avec
avec Madame anglaise
Jérôme Turcotte qui
ne veut plus faire partie du parti mais
était là enfin bref et Marc Tanguay chef
intérimaire on revient
on sait qu'on ne s'entend pas à
l'interne sur ses enjeux c'est correct
c'est normal ma manif il faut parler
c'est des accords là puis en arriver à
une conclusion
c'est surtout dans cette perspective là
c'est que c'est un enjeu qui est peu
abordé qui est mal abordé il est grand
temps pour nous d'arriver avec de
nouvelles propositions pour que le fait
français le fait nationaliste québécois
puisse s'inscrire au sein de la
fédération donc avec beaucoup d'audace
on a bien hâte d'en parler
bon est nationaliste si oui comment on
était dans des questions comme ça Alec
en fin de semaine
je connais Jérôme Turcotte depuis un bon
moment de la rentrée il y a plusieurs
années c'est un homme calme réfléchi pas
du tout une tête brûlée c'était avant
qu'il soit avec Dominique englade puis
c'est quelqu'un qui réfléchit beaucoup à
ces questions-là depuis longtemps donc
ça sortit sur le fait qu'il manquait de
québécitudes au Parti libéral du Québec
qui était parfois une succursale du
parti libérale du Canada qui manquait un
peu de mordant par rapport à comment
redéfinir le fédéralisme tout ça j'en
avais déjà discuté avec lui c'est très
cohérent avec sa vision depuis longtemps
je pense qu'il y aurait eu davantage de
de crédibilité de porter s'il ne s'était
pas déclaré orphelin politique avant de
se rendre au Conseil Général
Jérémie ma carte je fais plus partie de
la gagne mais je vais quand même aller
vous le dire en pleine face c'est un peu
particulier ça j'avoue mettons dans le
parti puis qui avait critiqué de
l'intérieur on aurait eu quelque chose
de plus intéressant comme des bottes
quelqu'un qui s'en retire qui fait son
adieu à ses compagnons d'armée mais sur
le fond il a raison aussi une réflexion
qu'on doit faire au parti libérale je
recevais en drop à disposition ce midi
qui est qu'au président de le comité de
relance du Parti libéral du Québec ils
ont en parle tout le temps dans toutes
les réunions avec les militants avec les
anciens chefs avec les députés comment
on peut se rapprocher d'électorat
francophone comment incarner d'une
manière moderne son nationalisme le sang
est celui de la CAQ qui évidemment pas
le même sens évidemment celui du PQ qui
est l'indépendantiste ça reste un
dilemme et ça reste compliqué on le sent
au Parti libéral d'avoir un nationaliste
plus affirmé sans avoir l'air de vouloir
ressembler à un autre parti politique
oui à partir du moment où il y a plus de
menaces référendaire Véronique le Parti
libéral qui a comme perdu un peu ses
repères puis la carque est en
nationaliste sans faire l'indépendant il
reste donc il reste moins une place un
peu là il y a des libéraux qui sont
traversés à la CAQ parce qu'ils étaient
plus nationalistes peut-être un peu
moins fédéraliste puis la taxe est
revendiquée comme le parti de l'économie
puis c'est un titre avant qu'on
attribuait au parti libérales alors
est-ce que c'est le parti de l'économie
ou non c'est est-ce que c'est le parti
qui défend les droits individuels Québec
solidaire puis le Parti québécois le
revendique aussi est-ce que c'est le
Parti des régions le PQ dit non c'est
nous la CAC aussi alors ils ont de la
difficulté à trouver leur espace puis
des gens comme Jérôme Turcotte je pense
qu'ils sont pas habitués de voir ce
genre de sortie là non plus dans les
congrès c'est le genre de choses qu'on a
vu dans le passé plus au PQ par exemple
parce que les libéraux même sans chef on
aurait pu penser qu'il y a des factions
qui auraient pu se créer avec des
nouveaux leaders des mouvements internes
pas vraiment ils sont restés comme
patients ils sont encore le parti bien
rangé malgré le fait qu'ils ont pas de
chef puis ils attendent patiemment les
recommandations justement du comité de
relance qui en passant ne vont pas lier
le prochain chef alors que c'est quand
même une variable importante les gens
qui nous écoutent doivent se demander
mais là ça fait quelques minutes qui
parle du PQ personne parle de la course
au lieu de chypreuse Hélène ils ne sont
pas pressés et les candidats ne sont pas
pressés pour lever la main non plus
d'ailleurs la dernière rumeur marchand
c'est quoi ça le maire de Québec
je peux peut-être pas parler
spécifiquement celle-là mais ce genre de
rumeurs là souvent
naissent autour d'une bière entre deux
Philippe champagne qu'on vient
d'entendre voilà et puis finalement on
se met à fantasmer sur quelqu'un
des fois ça fonctionne je pense à
Michael qui était avant avant d'être
malheureux chef libéral est un
prestigieux professeur d'université
alors des fois on se met comme ça
s'emballer jusqu'à ce que le candidat
s'il est flatté saute dans l'arène ou
autrement face comme Monsieur marchand
puis disent merci mais non merci ok mais
donc course à la chefferie allait qu'on
n'est pas très pressé
non on n'est pas pressé parce qu'on se
dit plus on attend on a peut-être de
candidats des candidatures intéressantes
qui vont pouvoir
s'intéresser à nous après des élections
fédérales par exemple qui pourrait venir
bien avant étant donné le gouvernement
minoritaire de Justin Trudeau certains
pensent après les élections municipales
moi je trouve ça un peu tard là c'est
innovembre 2025 les élections
municipales alors
moi je pense qu'attendre jusque là c'est
un peu tard mais bon il y en a qui
rêvent à une course très très tardive en
espérant que le bassin de quelque chose
se passe que monsieur se passe entre
temps
décide de partir mais il fait 10 fois
qu'il répète en 10 jours Véronique qui
est encore aujourd'hui le dire qu'on
fait que quand est avec Pierre
fitzgerbinet donne le goût de continuer
10 ans encore
oui mais oui effectivement moi aussi
j'ai été étonné d'entendre cette réponse
là comme si on mettait en doute le fait
qu'il voulait peut-être pas revenir pour
un troisième mandat il a dit qu'il
allait revenir que si ça sentait lui
permettait ok très bien on va reparler
des libéraux
David Jean Stone avait pas beaucoup
d'amis au Canada les gens font la ligne
pour dire à quel point il avait des
liens il est presque chinois d'une
certaine façon qu'on les entend et là je
savais que j'avais fait rire demain le
npda c'était gardé d'attaquer Johnston
en disant nous on va même accepter
d'aller lire le rapport secret on verra
ce qu'on en pense après mais demain NPD
à son tour réclame la démission de David
Johnson qu'est-ce qu'on doit comprendre
oui en fait c'est bizarre parce qu'il
monsieur je signe aujourd'hui fait une
conférence de presse exposant cette
notion mais en disant nous continuons à
avoir quand même confiance en Lui donc
il se base difficile sur perception il y
a une perception qui n'est peut-être pas
objectif et donc mieux vaut continuer
avec quelqu'un d'autre mais ce qu'on
comprend c'est que politiquement la
soupe est un peu chaude pour le chef du
NPD et en fait pour tout le NPD d'avoir
l'air d'être à la botte à la solde de
Monsieur Trudeau de dire ce qu'il
voulait entendre participer finalement à
cette grande initiative surtout que bon
évidemment il est son partenaire de
coalition de coalition qui dispose son
nom alors je pense qu'il y a un désir
comme ça de se distancer mais il y a
quelque chose d'un petit peu alambiqué à
dire on a encore confiance mais on va
comme s'appuyer ou donner raison à ceux
qui ont des perceptions en demandant son
dégommage il y a quelque chose d'un peu
incohérent me semble-t-il on veut
montrer que la question de posture qu'on
n'est pas qu'on dort pas totalement dans
le même lit avec
exactement et je suis pas certain que
même si la motion est adoptée
qu'il va y avoir une suite ça voudrait
dire pour le gouvernement Trudeau le
grosso modo de ranier même le premier
volet du rapport de dire c'est un là n'a
pas suffisamment la confiance des
Canadiens pour aller ensuite faire des
audiences publiques donc la première
partie non plus ne voudrait pas grand
chose je pense pas que les libéraux vont
aller là alors c'est vraiment du
positionnement politique le NPD qui est
statique et nous aussi on trouve
l'enquête publique serait nécessaire
mais on sait pas trop comment l'exiger
on va pas aller jusqu'à une motion
défiance à quelques semaines de l'été on
n'ira pas jusque là surtout qu'on sait
pas trop à quel point les Canadiens nous
pardonneraient de déclencher des
élections sur ça alors on va y aller
avec une espèce de motion mitoyenne ça
serait bien que les audiences publiques
soient présidées par quelqu'un d'autre
s'il vous plaît on pensait-y pour la
suite ça va aller très loin parce que
pour ceux qui suivent pas ça dans tous
les méandres Johnston doit présider des
des consultations publiques pour écouter
des gens pour dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ce problème de l'ingérence chinoise
entre autres mieux comprendre c'est
comme le volet 2 après son rapport 1
volley secret et là volait trois
ça serait c'est comme
tour de table qu'est-ce que le résultat
ce soir peut changer en Alberta sur les
relations fédérales provinciales si la
première ministre conservatrice que de
bonnes chances de l'emporter ce soir
disons-le Hélène l'emporte effectivement
madame Smith contre Riccio Nately qui
tente de revenir au pouvoir qui que ça
change si elle est élu pour vrai là si
je puis dire
ce qui est intéressant avec ce scrutin
c'est que quel que soit l'issue ça va
enquiquiner au moins un chef politique
fédéral alors si c'est madame se met
comme on le pense elle est quand même
prompte à des déclarations assez
controversées elle a parlé de
comparaisons avec Hitler et les vaccinés
etc ça pourrait venir plus tard
emmerder un peu pierrepoli avec je suis
certaine que les libéraux vont consigner
toutes les déclarations malheureuses
qu'elle fera pour essayer de les
attribuer à Monsieur polyèvre et si
c'est Madame notele évidemment
ça va cuisiner monsieur signe parce que
sur la question des pipines et du
pétrole sont pas du tout du même avis
climatiques le ton sera radicalement
différente de NPD de l'emporte beaucoup
plus facile pour le reste du Canada de
travailler qu'une Alberto dirigée par le
NPD même ce serait pas la panacée non
plus ce serait quand même plus facile et
Hélène a raison Daniel Smith c'est pas
pour rien que Pierre poliev ne lui a pas
donné un très gros appui il y avait un
petit vidéo il j'espère que tu gagnes
mais il est pas allé s'afficher avec
elle en campagne électorale c'est
vraiment un électron libre et là il y a
un risque pour le Parti conservateur
dans les prochains mois très bien merci
c'est tout le temps qu'on remercie à
vous trois on va surveiller c'est ce
soir
si ce soir donc l'élection